SHACKLE FORD, A LOCAL HORSE
TRAINER LEADING EFFORTS TO
EVACUATE ANIMALS AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I AM SO SORRY FOR WHAT YOU AND
EVERYONE IN YOUR COMMUNITY HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH.
ALMOST TOO MUCH TO COMPREHEND.
HOW ARE YOU PERSONALLY HOLDING
UP, BUT IF YOU COULD TAKE US
THROUGH SOME OF YOUR EFFORTS.
>> MY GOSH.
THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY SO I
APOLOGIZE.
I'M A LITTLE WEARY OVER HERE.
IT'S A HUMBLING EXPERIENCE TO BE
OUT HERE, AMAZING HOW A LOT OF
US, THE HORSE COMMUNITY REALLY
COMING TOGETHER, EVERYONE IS
DONATING WHAT THEY CAN COME IF
THEY CAN'T THEIR TIME, THEIR
FINANCES, THEIR RESOURCES, IT
REALLY DOES TAKE A VILLAGE TO
HELP EVERYONE OUT HERE.
ALL OF OUR HEARTS GO OUT, SO WE
ARE ALL WORKING TOGETHER VERY
CLOSELY TO COME TOGETHER AND BE
OUT HERE ARE THE PEOPLE, THEIR
ANIMALS, THEIR PROPERTY, THEIR
NEIGHBORS, THEIR FRIENDS, THEIR
FAMILY, IT'S BEEN VERY
DEVASTATING BEING OUT HERE.
>> Laura: I WAS SO HEARTENED
TO SEE THROUGH ALL THIS
HEARTBREAK AND TRAGEDY THAT
PEOPLE PUTTING ASIDE THEIR
DIFFERENCES, THEIR POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES, "WHAT CAN I DO TO
HELP YOU.
WHAT DO YOU NEED?
CAN I GET YOU A TRUCK, TRAILER,
FEED"?
"CAN YOU BRING YOUR ANIMAL TO MY
HOME"?
I'M A POLITICAL COMMENTATOR, BUT
THE BEST OF OUR COUNTRY COMES
OUT IN A TIME OF CRISIS, AND
THAT APPLIES TO POLITICIAN WHO
SHOULD SOMETIMES BUTTON IT AND
NOT COMMENT ON THINGS.
PEOPLE LIKE ME, I JUST APPLIED
ALL OF YOU FOR DOING WHAT WE
SHOULD DO TO HELP OUR FELLOW
MAN.
IT'S AWESOME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NORCAL LIVES EVACUATION AND
RESCUE.
WE ARE A BUNCH OF VOLUNTEERS PUT
TOGETHER, WE WORK INDIVIDUALLY
WITH THE OWNERS.
IF THEY WERE ABLE TO COME OUT
AND GET THEIR ANIMALS, CLOSELY
WORKING WITH CHP, RANGERS, GAME
WARDEN, MAKING SURE WE ARE ALSO
WITH THE PROPERTIES SO WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND BRING THEM BACK TO THE
VOLUNTEERS AND OTHER HELP
WORKING CLOSE WITH THE
VETERINARIANS TO GET THE ANIMALS
THEY HELP THEY NEED SO THEY CAN
BE REUNITED.
IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS GONE ON.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE WE ARE
LIKE, MAN, WE DO NOT WANT TO GET
ON FACEBOOK.
BUT IT HAS BEEN AMAZING AT HOME.
FACEBOOK, TWITTER.
>> Laura: THEY GOT IT DONE.
IT'S AMAZING.